He was the self proclaimed,
the Messiah who looked like a Rockstar,
a mesmerizing personality and Passionate
Bible knowledge combined to allow him
to gain ascendancy over a small group
of followers to manipulate them,
use them for his sexual desires,
and prepare them for his
own version of Armageddon.
Vernon,
Wayne Howell,
the child who would become David
Koresh was born on August the 17th,
1959 in Houston,
Texas.
His mother,
Bonnie Clark,
was just 14 at the time while his father,
carpenter,
bobby,
how was a 20 year old,
a drifter who abandoned his pregnant
girlfriend's when another girl caught his
eye,
Bonnie soon to come up with a
man who was a violent drunk.
They were married with a union
lasting for just two years.
They proved to be torturous.
He is for the infant.
He was often recall in later life
how his stepfather mistreated him.
When the marriage was dissolved,
Vernon was taken in by
his maternal grandmother,
Elaine Clark.
He grew into a likable,
but Mr Rothschild,
who was highly active.
In fact,
he was given the nickname sputnik due to
his boundless energy in recognition of
the Soviet satellite by age six,
Vernon was taken back in with his mother.
Bonnie has just married
a man by the name of Roy,
held a man when he moved
in with his mother,
she was pregnant again,
and in 1966 she gave birth to Vernon's.
His younger brother,
Ron Vernon,
struggled in school,
unable to keep up in elementary school
to the extent that he was placed in a
remedial class.
The other kids in his school
soon had a nickname for him.
Mr Retardo,
years later,
Vernon recalls the effects that this
ostracism has on his self esteem.
I mean your,
you know,
here comes the retarded kids and
it's like I stopped in my tracks.
It is believed that one of the main
reasons that Vernon struggled academically
was that he suffered from dyslexia,
rare condition,
which was little recognized at the time.
It was also a stutterer.
It was clear,
however,
that the boy wasn't stupid.
He has a natural mechanical ability and
loved nothing more than pulling gadgets
apart and putting them
back together again.
By the time it was a preteen,
Vernon's affinity with mechanics
that morphed into a love for cars.
It also lets him in a roundabout way to
music finding an abandoned and broken
guitar and a bond.
He fixed it up and began
teaching himself to play.
Vernon's other great
interest was in religion.
His family were seventh day adventists,
Cintas,
grandmother often had him
accompany how to church.
He was reared within the
confines of that way of worship,
which means no chasing after girls
taking drugs or going to teen parties.
While his peers were
engaged in those activities.
Vernon was busy reading the Bible and
is watching everything religious that he
could find on tv or read
in books and magazines.
By the age of 10,
he was able to recite long
passages of scripture.
Ends was giving his own many
sermons at home as a preteen then,
and we're still a statue.
You combined his passion for
scripture with his efforts.
Do overcome this speech impediments by
listening to powerful sermons on the
radio and then reciting the preachers
words he would study and emulates the
vocal skills of the speaker
discovering this when he did so,
his stutter disappeared.
Vernon's formal schooling finished when
he drops out during his junior year at
Garland high school.
If the 18 year old gained work
as a carpenter in gallons,
it was there that he began a relationship
with a 15 year old girl when she fell
pregnant to the girl's father,
became enraged.
He forced his daughter to break off the
relationship and warns Vernon to stay
away.
Vernon was in love with girl,
but so the only option,
but to heed the father's advice by now,
his family were living in Tyler,
Texas.
It was the ad was he approached his
local seventh day adventist elders and
really old style data to them.
He told them that he felt a moral
obligation to marry the girl.
He was surprised.
However,
when the eldest trying to
persuade him against doing so,
he had time to do reason scripturally
with them only to find that they were
getting angry with him.
In the ends,
they simply ordered
him to leave the church
as a result of Vernon situation,
not only here,
but his entire family were excommunicated
from the seventh day adventist church,
thoroughly disgusted
with the organization.
He began looking around
for an alternative church.
He was told about a group called the
branch Davidians who were based in Waco,
Texas.
The branch Davidians,
uh,
an offshoots of an offshoot
of the seventh day adventists.
This original group was founded in 1929
by a Bulgarian immigrants in theU ,
s named Victor,
who tiff originally cools
the shepherd's raags.
The sex was set up in Waco,
Texas.
The group were convinced that the
apocalypse was going to a car in 1959,
and when it didn't,
a group broke away under the leadership
of a man named Benjamin Roden,
he called this group the branch Davidians
in recognition of their holding to the
coming restoration of the
Davidic Kingdom of Israel.
In 1978,
roden died and his wife Lois
assumed leadership of the church.
Vernon Howell arrived at the
branch Davidian compound in 1980.
The 20 year old has long flowing hair,
a charismatic personality,
and a self effacing manner.
He appeared to be extremely spiritual
to those that he met at the compound
holding to a strict moral code and
judging himself as chief among sinners.
He turns up with his guitar and the
desire to use this music to reach young
people with the message of the Lord.
Lois Roden was immediately taken with
how old and she invited him to move into
the compound.
Before long,
the two became romantically involved,
despite the fact that
she was in her sixties,
lowest began to give vernon growing
prominence as a teacher at the compounds.
She would give them time at the pulpit
so he could expand his interpretations to
the congregation.
Vernon's preaching style
was very different to what
the church goers we're used
to experiencing.
He wore a t shirts and jeans and spoke
with illustrations that will often
startling and their directness.
On one occasion,
he likens sin to snot on a person's
finger that he just can't get off.
Above all,
he acknowledged himself
as imperfect as weak,
and does a center then
in his natural charisma,
has unkempt looks,
the downward style,
and his deep scriptural
knowledge where a potent mix.
He purposefully positioned himself in
the light of Jesus in opposition to the
state formulaic and have a critical
pharisees of mainstream religion.
His status was elevated even further
when he began to proclaim the gift of
prophecy.
A few months after Vernon had moved in,
though it's made the bombshell public
announcement that she was pregnant with
his child.
She told her followers this was all
part of God's divine arrangements.
However,
she would go onto miscarried the baby.
she still elevated Vernon as spiritual
as and as the next leader of the branch
Davidians.
Many in the congregation
were in agreements of Lewis's
consecration of Vernon as
her successor,
but there was one who was definitely
not and that would be lowest.
His son George George viewed
Vernon as a dangerous.
You suffer who is shamefully manipulated
his way into his mother's good graces
and was now poised to take over the
leadership that was rightfully George's to
inherit.
Over the next three years,
a power struggle was to play out between
Vernon and George with the congregation
split between the two.
Tensions came to a peak in
1984 when George and his
arm supporters forced Vernon
and about 25 of his followers to leave
the compounds at Mount Carmel for the
next two years.
This group was situated in Palestine,
Texas 90 miles away where they
had to live in buses and tense.
During this time,
vernon put his skills into building up
his base of followers through his music
and the power of his personality.
He was able to attract new
members from far and wide.
In 1985,
he traveled to Israel
with his pregnant wife,
Rachel Jones.
He was one of the congregation members.
It was while in the holy lands that he
became convinced that he was the modern
day incarnation of King Cyrus of Persia.
He had been tasked,
he claimed with opening the seven
seals of the book of revelation and
proclaiming them to all the world's back.
Now Common George Roden was
acting increasingly erratic,
which was causing his
followers to decline rapidly.
Many of the compounds openly supportive
Vernon howland's longs for his return.
Lois roden died in 1986 and George was
determined to eliminate the threats that
Vernon posed to his leadership.
He decided to call vern,
announced by challenging him
to a resurrection competition.
The man that could successfully raise
a dead person would be the acknowledged
leader of the church in order to achieve
a sentence and are clearly psychotic.
George has a body of zooms.
When Vernon heard about this,
he went directly to the authorities and
later complaints that George had been
tampering with a dead body.
He was told that the authorities could
do nothing unless they had photographic
evidence in order to obtain the needed
per that seven armed supporters into
Mount Carmel before they
could find the exuma body.
They were discovered by George's
followers and a gunfight broke out in the
skirmish region was wounded.
The police broke up the battle and Vernon
and his followers were arrested and
put on trial for attempted murder.
I need to later be acquitted of all
charges over the next couple of years.
Vernon's following it.
Palestine grew back at Mount Carmel.
George became even more irrational when
one of his supposed followers challenged
him,
claiming to be the messiah.
George lost control and
killed the man with an ax.
This act saw him being sent to a
hospital for the criminally insane
with George now well and truly out of
the way vernon and his followers oriented
the Mount Carmel Compounds.
He was now the undisputed leader of the
branch Davidians not long after his rita
and he had his name legally
changed to David Koresh.
Koresh is the Hebrew name for Cyrus,
who David was convinced he was the modern
day incarnation of with this new name
came the conviction that
Koresh was more than a prophet.
He was the Modern Day Messiah and the
words that he spoke were of divine origin
as the 19 nineties,
Dawn's David Koresh
was a 30 year old self,
proclaimed the messiah with a
young wife and two children.
He presided over more than 100 faithful
adherence who lived together in a single
large building,
having mastered the fusion of religious
music and inspiration or proselytizing,
Koresh's marathon sermons could last all
day and all night still for believers
would hang on his every word.
Gresh began using his position as the
revealer of God gone well to announce
supposedly divine decrees that were
increasingly to his personal advantage.
One of the most controversial was that
all of the women in the complex were to
be available to him at any time.
For his sexual pleasure is included.
All of the married women as well Koresh
did not confine his sexual liaisons to
adult women.
Girls as young as 12
became his sexual partners.
These girls had been convinced that to
give themselves over to God in the form
of Koresh was the greatest
privilege that they could attain.
The men of Mount Carmel,
including those who were married,
were to remain celibate.
This was because there was only one
seed that was holy and it flowed from,
uh,
Koresh.
As a result,
the majority of the children that the
complex where his at the time of his
death,
he was father to 15 sons and daughters.
While the majority of the branch Davidians
excepted this arrangement is the will
of God.
There were a handful of dissenters.
You left the church because of some
of those who left were Australian.
When they returned back home to Australia,
they went to the American embassy and
child abuse charges were laid against
Koresh back in the United States.
Other factors made some electronics
in response to the allegations.
Child protective services
sent investigators to the
Mountain Carmel Complex.
Their specific brief,
however,
was to assess the validity of an
accusation that children had access to.
Firearms Koresh,
however,
showed that all of the firearms wonder
lock and key and child protective
services.
They closed the case in the wake of the
defections Koresh became increasingly
angry and violent towards his followers.
When one woman expressed a
desire to take a child and leave,
he denied her to teach her a lesson.
He rapes her.
Even winslow recounted the incident is
a warning to the congregation at this
time his sermons,
they became darker with the constant
theme of the Coming Day of judgment.
He told his followers that Armageddon
was going to be initiated or right there
at Mount Carmel and so that they have
to be prepared to give up their lives in
order to usher in the Davidic Kingdom.
By 1992 Koresh had imbued a siege
mentality into the minds of his followers.
The governmental authorities.
They were agents of the devil ends.
They were preparing for a cataclysmic
showdown with the true followers have gone
to a hold up at Waco
by divine inspiration.
Koresh revealed that he had been
instructed to stockpile weapons at the
compounds.
Davidson discovers that the trading
of guns was a lucrative business,
providing much needed
funds for the ongoing costs
associated with the compounds.
He would have members buying up cheap
weapons and then selling them at gun trade
shows.
Any excess money would be used
to build up that rational.
Meanwhile,
the information about the presence of
weapons in Mount Carmel had been passed on
by the agents who had visited from
child protective services to the FBI who
would in turn given it
to the bureau of Alcohol,
tobacco,
and firearms.
The ATF now began
surveillance of the property.
The situation winds up a notch when the
ups delivery package was seen by agents
to contain hands grenades,
which were illegal.
This discovery led to an eight month
investigation which revealed a trend of
everything from grenade launchers to
assault weapons ending up at Mount Carmel
by early November of 1992.
The ATF had amassed enough evidence
to take Koresh into custody.
They will worried though
that his followers,
he sincerely believed
that he was the Messiah,
would fight to stop them
from taking him away.
They could have arrested him when
he was in town buying supplies,
but for some reason they chose not to.
Instead,
they placed some undercover agents in a
small cabin that was situated right in
front of the entrance to the compounds.
One of the agents,
Robert Rodriguez manage to friends members
of the group and get himself invited
to a Bible study class where you
could observe Koresh shop close.
The ATF concluded that Koresh was an
imminent danger to society who could
unleash his followers and they're lethal
force upon any target at any time.
They decided that the best course of
action was to stage a raid on his complex.
The date was set for February the 28th,
19,
92,
an hour before the raid was
scheduled to go down under cover.
Agent Rodriguez went into the compounds
and showed Koresh that morning's copy of
a local paper with it's blazing headline,
the Sinful Messiah alongside
a picture of Koresh Koresh.
You had already been informed that there
was a buildup of law enforcements and
media around the area told her dri guys
that he knew that the ATF were about to
attack upon exiting mounds,
Carmel Rodriguez,
trying to warn his atf bosses that Koresh
already knew about the surprise rate,
but it was too late.
Fully armed agents were already
closing in on the compounds.
To this day,
it remains unclear as to
which side fired first,
but within a fist firefight was underway.
Moving 70 ATF officers were
secret ID around the building.
While army helicopters cycled above
inside branch Davidian members put fire on
the invaders who had come
to take away that Messiah.
The shooting lasted for
more than 60 minutes.
Koresh was hitting the wrist while six
of his followers were shot dead for ATF.
Agents were also killed.
As the fighting continued Koresh
made a phone call to the local police
departments urging that
the rate be stopped,
the request,
it fell on deaf ears and he hung
up and proceeded to go upstairs.
It was then that he was
wounded a second time.
This time more seriously,
the bullet penetrated his hip,
confining them to the floor.
When the shooting ended,
the ATF had multiple
casualties and no David Koresh.
The handling of the raid was roundly
condemned leading to intervention by the
FBI with worldwide attention
now focused on Waco.
The new men in charge were determined
to ends the standoff as quickly as
possible.
Final battle that Koresh
had been proclaiming for so
many years was now upon his
followers with him were
117 of the faithful,
including 46 children and nobody
wanted to leave but Koresh sent out 14
children,
none of which were his offspring
in the days after the raise Koresh.
His main preoccupation during the siege,
which was to last for 51 days,
was to get his message
about the seven seals,
sounds the wells the rave had created
a media frenzy and he believed that he
could capitalize on the publicity to
get the word out for hours on end.
He proselytized over the
phone to FBI negotiators.
Three days after the raid Koresh agreed
to bring out all of his followers.
If you get one of his
sermons ad on the radio,
this was Julie.
You complied with,
but Koresh failed to live up
to his side of the bargain,
claiming that God had told him to
hold off until you received further
instruction.
After two weeks,
foods,
water and milk for the young
children was running dangerously low.
Inside the compounds Koresh told his
followers that the hardship they were
facing was a direct test
of their faith in him.
Things got worse when the FBI caught
off all power to the complex and began
playing loud music and shining blazing
lights throughout the night in order to
prevent the branch Davidians from sleeping
still the people inside it would not
budge,
crash,
and then last thing,
I'll say trickle of people thus far,
but now he angrily declared that no one
else would leave Mount Carmel so long as
the government kept up the torments
and increasingly frustrated.
FBI now brought in Abrams tanks which
proceeded to smash and destroy all
property outside of the compounds,
including vehicles with the pressure
tactics falling flat to the FBI allowed a
defense attorney hazed by Koresh's
mother to go in and talk to his clients.
Gresh told the lawyer that he knew that
the government would not let him live
even though the FBI had offered to arrange
for a worldwide television broadcast
of his message if he promised to come
out is trusting them was shattered and he
refused the offer.
There was a breakthrough of sorts on
April the 14th when Koresh announced that
golden instructed him to write down the
entire message of the seven seals of
when this majestic work was completed.
As promised,
the siege would be over and the
branch Davidians would come out.
The seven seals offer,
however,
was never passed onto us.
Attorney General Janet Reno,
who want April [inaudible]
17 for authorized the plan
to use tanks and tear gas
to bring this to an end.
The end's began at 6:00 AM on April the
19th when an FBI agents phoned Koresh
and told him that tear gas was being
placed in the building by mechanical arms
attached to tanks.
He stressed that it was not an assault
and urge the Davidians not to fire their
weapons.
Batang smashed into the
building as it delivered.
CS,
gas and size of the people were in agony,
unable to breathe and feeling as if
their strikes and the lungs were on fire.
Still maybe came out after
six hours of fire erupted,
which quickly got out of control.
Now surely I'll look his reasons.
Those inside would come out,
but it wasn't to be the fire
raged through the building,
killing 17,
nine people,
including 22 children,
Koresh had made his way to the
chapel with the flames closing in.
He died of a gunshot wound to the hat.
Nobody knows whether or not
he claimed his own life.
So I really hope you found
this video interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below and
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
bell so you get notified
when we put out new videos.
Normally do a couple of these every week.
Some of them don't like this,
others of them a little more light,
so if you've liked that sort of stuff,
hit subscribe and like also trying out
some other videos linked to on the screen
now and as always,
thank you for watching.